the final set of secrets to the final
DLC of the last Souls game and it's
fitting that in this DLC there are some
of the best secrets of all case in point
number one I cannot find an energy body
and I've searched high and low once it's
over here in the first place
purging Monument you can see it but how
do you get there this question
completely absorbed like over ten hours
of my play time and the only location I
could conceivably find that could
possibly lead there is this shoot
leading upwards and behind a broken
statue engraved upon the wall other
words show your humanity I was lucky
enough to play the DLC a couple of days
before it was public and I couldn't rely
on bodies amazing videos to help me
figure this riddle out so I tested all
kinds of things for hours and hours on
end I tried to get the her alt headpiece
I cast all kinds of abyss magic
I tried chameleon I did all the friendly
human gestures I died in front of it I
did everything on my massive checklist
until I discovered I was using chameleon
in the wrong place see chameleon is
based off your immediate environment not
the general vicinity which is what I
thought it was so if you cast it atop
the abyssal swamp then you will turn
into a humanity sprite which reveals a
ladder
[Music]
which leads to a final do Decatur giant
two rings nights and the purging
monument of the Ring City are you
certain that now sorry I know you never
lie to me
thank you thank you kindly I'll speed
right on over
won't be long now before I know
everything who I was what I live for
what my name was and I'll have you to
thank for it all I swear upon my
birthday that I am your friend no matter
what might come out no matter what I was
if you would do me the honor allow me to
be a true friend always of course that
deserves his own video but find the
purging Monument before he goes hollow
and you'll restore your dear friends
memories and in the shared grave he
shows his true self Oh
finally you've come now I know exactly
who I was and for that I've a little
thanks to be giving go this way and
people ask the broken staircase some
awfully fine treasures just sitting
there all alone
it'll change your life
[Music]
every page is tainted by the greed of
men rubbish to one such as I avoid a
more worldly wants I didn't maybe just
the way we are I'll stick you in my
friend a fine dark soul to you patches
is one of the very few undead who made
it to the end of the world
think about that he made it through all
those cycles and ages of fire to get
here like you and like Gayle did so
bearing that in mind I think that his
words carry a lot of weight his ashes
say he never lost heart and never looked
back he marched in one direction and
that direction was dead ahead
number three beyond the shared grave is
dark eater Medea the arch dragon who was
tasked to eternally battle and consume
the dark as you progress through the
reigning city
look behind you sometimes Medea takes
perch upon multiple towers of the Ring
City watching and waiting for the
perfect moment to strike oh that's nice
of him he chose bridge where I can take
cover - out attack and just rinse and
repeat until Medea falls into the chasm
so medea hat into the cabin fallen still
his voice I hear the dark grieveth him
yet I prithee put him to rest before the
dark consume with him and his vows of
forgot just before the Church of the
princess standard the tower honoring
ancient nights there lies the small
shrine behind the scouts at night which
bears no ax to trim their one may ascend
the chasm of Darkness I prithee put the
great dragon to rest Medea descendant of
arch dragons was raised by the gods and
due to his immortality he was the
perfect candidate to battle the dark but
he would never forget his eternal duty
even after the gods perish
from m'dear you discover a covenant with
the spheres of the church Knights who
are sworn to the defense of princess
Fillion or there's a small shrine to the
spears that you can find outside the
church of Fillion or here you can
contribute spear ornaments one of which
drops from the agro bossfight offer one
and Shera will acknowledge your
condiment oh now now a spear of the
church but a wonderful blessed day this
is with a sphere such as we surely the
princess will slumber most gently and
Madhu's vows will be honored and with
the covenant equipped you will be
summoned by the judicata into the worlds
those who trespass upon the Church of
billion or kill a trespasser and you'll
receive a sphere ornament proof of your
fulfillment of duty if you are 410 then
you receive a young grass do offer 30
and you receive a divine spear fragment
which is used against online foes and
it's at this point that you'll be named
a divine spear the church by Shira ah a
Divine Spirit becomes an honor once was
stoned in the time of the gods nearly
unheard of in this age of raining fire
as a servant of the princess and friend
to Medea I am honoured to admit thee
this game isn't life for me right now so
I can't test this but assumedly players
are summoned into the boss fight itself
instead of half light to fight against
other players you know old monk style
and mirror knight style which is such a
shame because I've already killed Argo
and that means I can't test this for
myself unless I make a new character if
only there was a way to revive him oh
you can just travel back to the purging
Monument for some reason and for the low
low price of a hundred and three
thousand souls you too can experience
the fight
next number six the lightning arrow
miracle that Shearer uses in this room
before you fight Argo and after you
first face Medea is an illusory wall and
behind it there's another illusory wall
and behind that is another illusion wall
and then there's the lightning arrow a
miracle that was used by the few female
Knights who served in the war against
the Dragons number seven I want to talk
about fillion or specifically her name
because one thing we really really
haven't touched on at all in my videos
is the etymology of certain names in
Seoul's Miyazaki clearly pulls from all
kinds of languages when he designs these
names and a lot of them are really quite
beautiful and Fillion or is the perfect
example she is the youngest daughter of
gwyn lord of sunlight and there are two
components this named Fillion law that
were posted first I think on reddit by a
user named Knight frost so the first
part of her name philia means daughter
in latin and the second part a noir
means son in elvish and is of course
what inspired the name anor londo philia
nor the daughter of the son the daughter
of Gwyn there is another interpretation
you can go with now this was posted by
Dark Soul winners and he or she says
that the word nor is Latin for
daughter-in-law which casts some new
meaning on whether Fillion or could
actually have had a different mother to
the other children of win and with
Yoshika somehow being revealed to be a
child of Gwyn as well it becomes less
and less surprising that we're learning
about more and more of wins many
children number eight the ring burdened
pygmy statues a revelation in this DLC
is the circumstances surrounding the
first men and the gods so as an example
from the ringed knife set we learned
that early men were originally very
close to the abyss and that while their
Warriors actually fought with the gods
against the arch dragons in that famous
war they also suffered at the gods hands
afterwards for the gods seemed to fear
the abyss
so they branded the armor and the
weaponry of the Knights with a seal of
fire occluding the darkness of the abyss
and this brand of course has appeared
time and time again this great burden to
mankind and here in the ring city we
learn more about how it came about and
we'll go into this so much more in other
videos so subscribe if you haven't
already I just want to say I love that
the burden of the seal is represented so
literally by these statues next we've
mentioned this before but depending on
whether you kill the demon from below or
the demon in pain first that determines
whether you get the fireball demon
prints or the laser demon prints and
originally the demon Prince fight
actually featured only one bat at the
start with the second one
appearing halfway and additionally I
also want to point out that the
description of the soul of the demon
Prince has changed from what I said
earlier it now reads the demons curved
from a common chaos share almost
everything between them even the pride
of their prince and his near faded flame
so that the last demon standing may
rekindled the description before this
revealed that this was indeed the demon
prince that was defeated by lothric and
that in this hollow tree he lost the
memory of flame that burned within him
which marked the end of demon's kind and
they removed this description
so I think they were trying to imply the
death of demon kind more in this new
description because now neither the
demon in flame nor demon from below
remain alive to rekindle the final climb
of chaos and finally number 10 kill the
stone hump hag at the beginning and this
happens my time has come
love it well maybe I get to see danger
sure enough an angel does appear but
this one is curious compared to the
others as far as I can tell it doesn't
actually reappear once you kill it like
the other ones for it has no discernible
fleshy avatar parasite thing on the
ground like the others that grow over
the corpses of pilgrims and perhaps this
angel is a resurrection of the hag but
the parasite has yet to grow inside of
them unless there's something I'm
missing here there is no material
benefit to killing the hag nor from
killing any NPC in the ring city really
lack the core being the pygmy the
locusts none drop a thing so I'm
currently lacking about 4 more things to
make another one of these videos and I
know there's more out there that I
haven't found yet so if there's anything
that you've discovered posted here in
the comments and I'll try give you a
shout out in the next one so good luck
out there enjoy the ring city and I'll
enjoy making videos you to enjoy when
you're done see you soon
[Music]